right one in four points given indeed
John DeLuca took a look at this
what pass got it off in time plenty of
time what a shot
Wow he is a special young man there's no
question about it by the way that was a
heck of a pass by crosses and yes it
would burn her looks blades it into tray
two seconds watch rays flutter
[Applause]
desert
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perfected and getting all
the love on the sideline no man he's put
together a heck of a game
[Applause]
Luka against Austin Rivers brings it
down towards a minute to play in the
first quarter
[Applause]
Kevin looking long to the basket away
[Applause]
and Winston in overtime but basket is
good on video review
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Dallas it's got the lead dodge it
throws down a sledgehammer don't sleep
on Luka open early had to miss met you
thought I was gonna let up now I'm
touching it on you Conley six seconds
five beverage poops it up spins in tour
nerd tray beats the buzzer and hits the
three-pointer six seconds hustles it
down the floor got Garrett Teflon away
with a fake and buries the three of the
Hawks are back within four
dodge it okay
oh yeah we like that off balance that's
it
judge with the handle the control and
everything that has made him the most
accomplished international player that
has ever come into the analysis only got
one rats in a possession of all game
[Applause]
[Music]
how about to handle how about the spin
Vince gets him a little bit of
separation the close by cleaver my
goodness I tell you that's reminiscent
of a handle like Steph Curry but his
favorite the advantages would be SJ and
those two doctors was in the 2017 draft
last year played overseas tray with a
supermoon man good Don Cheech handling
into the frontcourt for the Mavericks
behind the back dribble to the rim at
all would have finished
you got we'll run more picking local
rolls with white side if you don't it's
gonna be tough oh look at Kevin and
assists number 10 comes right here I
mean Matt Ryan would be thrilled to see
that fan Oh is that's a pinpoint one and
raised outside North America Nate is
dousset as an assistant in the NBA the
last 18 years gotcha - another great
pass to the Andre Jordan that's gonna be
a talent to watch this year five seconds
for pray over midcourt Winslow defending
weights trailing it too
[Applause]
they heat the trap right here but
there's three guys he goes between three
and meets a fourth guy at the rim nice
little floater to get his twentieth
point on the beach today
Inka Jordan
Oh his second so out of the game he's
going to go here's Lucas handles gonna
get some Globetrotter stuff to this year
so it's gonna be fun curly Neal's get
out look at that
good boy you faked me out no player
likes to look where the
[Applause]
did that go in to finish in the open
court it's for dicks all over it yeah
amp nice spin move back to his right
hand cancer a little bit too late he
goes up on Luca jazz had the foul again
[Applause]
-
he gave it to me and closed the second
quart out the way they did they're going
to be a control eight-foot poop very
reluctant to take but he made it pray
from just inside towards the Indiana
trip January jam by cleaver
well last minute take a look so you made
the cut looker with the supreme vision
for the Jam bankrupt lost it great picks
it up leads the break train leaves it
for harder off the turnover I step back
Trey young behind the back to Kevin here
comes
[Music]
Christine told me at shootaround today
it's really so Anna's down there right
now heart I've got white up guy he told
me tonight and shoot around it was just
a pickle gjp no G
[Applause]
Wow
so Trey Young has now dribbled between
two guys lay they later Negara lado for
defensive play Luca very alertly
guarding LeBron James on the knees
LeBron didn't said the first time with
the second time
[Applause]
for a bounce for the dump and watch
drown on this place Aware's oh no way I
don't know he hadn't run anyway yet he's
at the rim
Derrick Dedmon throwing one down as have
made him work for this one
you wanna do good look tough right here
[Applause]
one to the finish it's a great dog
excellent pass for blue cook on the
basket ray shot clock at three great
let's it fly at headset one a rainbow
three four three
shot clock winding down but he doesn't
let this one fly but again he got a
watch that right leg Jonas Jerebko went
into the game and Luca goes right around
now that ducks again on he went down
hard there you go it's strong it is the
pick and choose what you go for when it
comes to notes just with that quick step
three was seven six trains gonna launch
from deep it looks like yep there it
comes
[Applause]
it water check it out
you gotta make them
deep freeze while we baked it in
[Music]
The Legend of Luca continuing to be
written for the rookie smart toppling
off as he contested that was clearly a
foul dodge MacGuffin should have gotten
the three hand one
[Music]
stay tuned Alex went seven second six my
second stray try to what it
ladies that ties the game and just
weaves his way through all those white
shirts one-minute lips
[Applause]
deadpan rebounds lead pass
[Applause]
just another great pass from have this
fancy it's beyond half court right on
point unless you let him water left and
wide-open force it have to be to shoot a
good cut right here so Neil latest baler
he was a teammate of torian's in college
[Applause]
he froze the entire interior deep back
to the jab move one more time from Trey
young you see the trap right there and
he kind of faked them out with the
dribble that's knocked out and rudy Gay
can live there I mean even hurt some but
[Applause]
at the great finish that time by yo Luca
he practices that stuff need with a
three and Trey has that bounce in his
step
[Applause]
trae Young gets him out of their seats
one more times watch this fakes the
behind the back that goes through his
legs and drew the foul on Collison his
second Barnes draws the defense touch
pass by Matthews Luke at the end of the
shot clock got it back with Dennis it's
gonna come back to me Luke are you ready
let's see the beneficiary at the all
these whistles with free throws great
Young's weekend George Hill he's getting
behind Trey and Trey's gonna make him
pay and watch this trade three I mean
look ways that when he released it
there's no defense there right now
[Applause]
this is all Luka here just attack it in
the open court and showing off that
tremendous skill
lay off the ball a little more give the
ball up when the traps are coming you
know they're coming
but you see right he gets all the way to
the basket get your player from Colorado
half-court heat Center well if you're
looking for a lifeline maybe that's one
the good-looking young flare
that's why he's in the store in Lana
tray young with the rainbow is getting
long I mean this is no set boxes on foot
watch ticks and down low
wanna fight by touch 2220 in one and
here's lucca with the up up one more
time let me give it to you like kevin
mchale used to give it to us mr. prince
two and a half minutes in hawks looking
to score tray goes baseline
[Applause]
again here's all skill Luca on the in
Dettman to hurt her
one second lap trach beats the buzzer
tray young with 11 he comes up with this
hoop did it beat the buzzer a jerk did
he turned 21 years old on Sunday Dennis
Smith jr. he had the ball on the right
side fed it to DeAndre through traffic
went to the corner same spot where Luca
made one you said it the matador the
harder it is the easier he makes it
looked a little step back that time
nothing but cool coaches used to say
stop at the foul line
oh yeah story puts it in it's gone
because if you stop at the free-throw
line together you got three options you
can you got your own shot all right
or you just pull it out get back to join
the little collection Derek's got it
back guillotine tongs
[Applause]
and there's also been a foul call as
well
[Applause]
that's the presence rocks moving that
basketball five assists on eight field
goals today crayons
we'll work at this three-pointer by Trey
young this is a tough shot I mean it
hits the back of the rim when you get a
little love there and it falls in anyway
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content